genauso ist dass vitali klitschko haben
wir bürgermeister von kiew die
entscheidende frage auch wenn viele
deutschen wie steht es momentan um die
hauptstadt die frage ist immer noch kann
die russische armee die hauptstadt
einkesseln oder nicht nein auf keinen
fall hierzu moment zu suchen unsere
soldaten kämpfen und
kämpferisch dass alle sind helden
deswegen die pläne an gästen der stadt
war schon vor zwei wochen und bis heute
der user ist noch wie viele pläne nicht
geführt deswegen deswegen dank an unsere
dann unsere soldaten
kämpfen so gut
jetzt immer mehr rund läuft ein bisschen
ruhig heute weil
gibt keine kämpfe um kiefer war heute
eine grüne korridore für ihre landsleute
von jörg pastoor mail von buschehr von
apple vor ordentlichen in worte
bisher
40.000 leute vor ort können wir nicht
genau sagen aber wir schätzen das kann
mehr als 20 aufklärung 2000 wird berührt
jetzt gab es heute gespräche zwischen
dem klinischen außenminister und dem
russischen außenminister die erstmal zu
nichts geführt haben wie viel hoffnung
hast du das in den nächsten tagen es
frieden geben kann oder müssen uns auf
einen monat lang krieg einstellen keiner
weiß bescheid kein experte keine politik
in die welt gar antwort zu geben weil
alle raststation will sind
wir sind abhängig von nur 1 vor mein
mann sieht und kreml in moskau von herrn
putin und deswegen er entscheidet
entscheidet level nicht und wir sind
alle so abhängig von im kreml momentan
sitzt gerhard schröder ehemaliger
bundeskanzler dem gremium kämen zusammen
mit wladimir putin und gibt es einen
bericht der zeitung politico wonach das
auf eine klinische initiative eines
abgeordneten konzerns gm hervorgeht um
sozusagen putin zu verhandlungen mit ihm
druck zu machen siehst du da eine chance
dass schröder kann und das ist so etwas
führt
hoffen wir also denke ich mal
das ist schwierig das ist ein von der
ubs experten wie hier und das ist die
stimmung die schon angefangen zu sagen
keine einzige staat ist keine einzige
stadt ist
erobert in dur einem ja das ist
die ukrainische armee zeigt eine sehr
gute ergebnis und dass es noch
akzeptieren creme oder den erst lucas
das ist viel zu wenig für putin den
preis und jetzt die denken
hin zu finden eine eine
weg sein gesicht zu verlieren weil das
es begründung muss da sein wo ist
das sinnlose krieg und einfach wir alle
hoffen dass es wird eine diplomatische
lösung aber kann die ukraine ein
neutrales land werden wie österreich
beziehungsweise kann die ukraine auch
eine nato-mitgliedschaft verzichten das
was
ich möchte noch einmal in vergangenheit
zu kommen der suche hat die dritt ist
die
dritte größte
waffen die nuklearwaffen
hat der
atome bis 1994 und wir wollen frieden
und ich haben freiwillig unsere atom-
war vom abgeben für garantie
garantie das ist keine greift unsere
lanthan und das ist russin auch auf
unsere unabhängigkeit und die teile so
wird garantiert
und wie sehen heute diese garantie
funktioniert gar nichts
überhaupt nicht funktioniert haben und
dann noch das so gesehen dass creme wenn
ihr es lugansk und wir glauben an uns
und nicht mehr gleichzeitig gibt es
heftige kämpfe in mario programm gesehen
wie raketen dort ein kinderkrankenhaus
getroffen haben und wie es dort viele
viele tote gibt tausende zivilisten in
die tools sind wie ist die lage in der
gesamten rechnung ich spreche ich
spreche hier ständig mit bürgermeister
von maria oberloher erzählt mehr die
schlimme situation das ist eine richtige
gegner zieht weil sie sehr viele
zivilisten sterben da und des staates
formuliert
genau das gleiche
ähnlich die situation in haiti in andere
städte wie zum beispiel werden aber
nicht so weit vom tief
das ist ein alptraum die ich weiß nicht
wie kann ich das alles beschreiben die
jede der wunsch von jedem trainer das
sind schnell wie möglich zu stoppen
mit arbeit nicht auf
preisträger sind die ständigen beruf
sachen ja bitte keine waffen keine nato
zu akzeptieren das denn jetzt
und danach wir sehen gäbe oder gelegt
das ist sehr gefährlich dass es schon da
und nicht fair bedingungen vielen
deutschen fragen sich in diesem moment
was können sie tun um der ukraine zu
helfen ihr habt ein großes spendenkonto
eingerichtet wie den menschen helfen
flüchtlingen was ist das der die hilfe
die ukraine die kiab jetzt im moment in
diesem moment braucht eine messe für
alle in deutschland wir kennen wir nicht
nur für durchgehend für die werte für
den prinzipien und genau das gleiche
werte hat alle europäische lernt er das
ist sinnlose krieg und ich noch keiner
sagen
großvater volk in
die kabine folgen
in georgien auch
wo die dem gremium hat keine strafe
dafür bezahlt werden der erfolgreiche
operation wird sehen dass es vielleicht
die nächste wird die baltischen länder
oder holland und deswegen
deswegen ich habe schon gesagt ich
möchte noch einmal wiederholen das ist
ein wolf konzerne verlieren aber
charakter sein haradinaj und deswegen
man muss richtig aufpassen dass cannes
treffen die jeder europäer unsere unsere
geheimnis das ist unser schlüssel für
unsere für uns riesig das ist so ja beim
gemeinsam alle länder in europa
gemeinsam gemeinsam kämpfen sie für die
werte für das prinzip die unterstützung
noch reiner www wir sind bereit für
unsere unabhängigkeit zu kämpfen und
dafür brauchen wir unterstützung
bedanken führung der gemeinde
helfe wir bekommen sehr viele
finanzielle unterstützung wir werden uns
sehr sehr dankbar für einen waffen
unterstützung weil wir stehen vor den
stacks termin gewählt aber die war
verspielt auch wichtige rolle und
danke für unterstützung durch eine ich
war geht's dann präsidenten gebäude
würden sie denn sie haben ihn interviewt
und habe ihm die frage gestellt was er
seinen kinder sagt wenn seine kinder
sagen papa du stehst hier auf einer
liste und davon liest und erfährt wie
die situation ist auch für die
persönliche und viele menschen fragen
auch nicht ständig wie geht es den
fiskus warum sind sie noch da ich mit
diesem fall schon häufiger gestellt aber
was macht das auf b sie liest er steht
die ukraine
sicher jetzt im moment wenn eine adresse
greift unsere lanthan und deswegen und
deswegen
und deswegen
früh schnell wie möglich liste bildet
jetzt schnell wie möglich frieden in
unserem land aber
die anwohner hat mich als bürgermeister
gewählt die vom bonner hat mehrere
gegeben die sein interesse zu
sein leben zuschuss und interessen zu
verteidigen und deswegen das ist meine
mission mein land meine stadt zu
verteidigen und die menschen zu
verteidigen
als ehemalige soldat habe ich schon mal
gespürt
[Musik]
mein land zu verteidigen beim land
braucht man mich und das dauerte bislang
lebenslang letzte frage witali klitschko
gewann glaubst du kannst du mal wieder
nach deutschland fahren auch zu deiner
familie die kinder die lange wird dieser
krieg da
ich weiß nicht eine kleine antwort ihr
koffer und flog eine woche vielleicht
zwei monate ich weiß nicht was
deine ich hoffe dass schnell wie möglich
frei kommt für reine und alle
flüchtlinge kommt wieder zurück nach
unsere städte nach rheine die frage kann
ich nicht antworten leider dass es habe
nicht vor mir aber wissen was ich mag
ich tue alles fast von mir abhängt die
frieden trug zum unserer wahl zu bringen
herzlichen dank vitali klitschko und
damit in diesem interview austria zurück
nach berlin